what else we got here oh this is really
important we got it we got to cover this
so demi lovato
as you know i'm a big fan of demi lovato
uh who mostly i think she what is she
non-binary now or no she's pansexual
or no lesbian but she's
she was lesbian and then went pansexual
and most recently she's non-binary
so she's been going through this uh this
little bit of transformation
and um
now she has also come out as a believer
in aliens
and so this brings together it's like
two of my worlds are colliding demi
lovato aliens
she's she even has a show now i think
where she goes on on the hunt for
for aliens and here she is on the e news
channel talking about her own
experiences with uh space aliens very
interesting listen
do you believe in ufos
well demi lovato does in her new show
unidentified with demi lovato demi drags
their sister and best friend into the
woods to hunt for the unexplained and
they told aaron all about it
what is that oh my goodness wait this is
so crazy convince us why we should watch
the show we laughed a lot and we saw
some really interesting things that we
catch on camera i just have a curiosity
about this topic that i've always
i've always had and
and so i wanted to find out for myself
say hi to night vision high night vision
and you two were pretty skeptical at
first what was the turning point for you
yeah i mean i identified as a
non-believer coming in and i would say
i'm definitely a lot less of a skeptic
than i was before with all this ufo
stuff like
you know being open and being ready to
accept it helps and i think we were and
i think that shows and demi you had an
encounter before shooting the show can
you please give us the details on that
experience we went out into the desert
in joshua tree and i basically saw like
this blue orb that
was about 50 feet away
maybe less and
it was just
it was kind of like floating above the
ground just like 10 or 15 feet but was
keeping its distance from me and i don't
know it just
um it was really it was a really
beautiful and incredible experience
yeah i think those might have been the
drugs that you were taking but no i
actually no i i beli listen
i believe you
demi lovato i believe you on this
uh some of the other claims you've made
about yourself i i find a little bit
hard to believe like that you're both
both men and women all all at once
contained within one person
that part i'm not sure about but
aliens i believe i believe you
i hear you
you are valid
and i i just i buy it
and i say that mostly unironically
there are too many people who have had
these experiences
and how do you how do you explain it all
i mean i i guess you know there are a
lot of
a lot of potential explanations but none
of them as interesting as the
explanation that we're being visited by
uh space aliens why do they keep coming
here in their in their orbs and then
leaving
it's like coming a long way and then
leaving and then they just they keep
coming you think whatever they were
looking for they would have found by now
and realize that this is not where they
want to be
so i can't explain any of that
i mean in demi lovato's case i guess i
can't explain it
if these uh
these aliens came all this way many
light years and they're they're about to
land on earth
and the first people they see
are demi lovato and her crew
you can't really blame them for saying
never mind guys we made a mistake let's
get out of here
let's go check out jupiter instead
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated